[Music]
you are about to enjoy a free preview of
disney's jungle cruise
hello
francoise ah there you are i was hoping
we might have a small business chat not
a good chat time right now
but if you came back first thing
tomorrow morning lots of available chat
then no i would much prefer now my name
is dr lily houghton and my brother and i
are looking for passage upriver and i'm
told that you are the man for the job
you were told wrong that's impossible
because you come
highly recommended i have an idea
please go away mr nilo your name is
plastered all over the boats outside i
think you're
being a bit unreasonable you're the one
trying to break down my door
i have a lot of money
you're insistent it's been said
now we're headed up river in the
direction of the peruvian andes this
region doesn't really have a name on the
conventional map but
it was once known to some
as la grimas de cristal
you're wearing pants
trousers and yes as are you do women in
england do that now well we're not in
england last time i checked and i look
as shocking as the pants are i really
don't cause me manny
mike calls me money
frank owes me money can i get you a
drink who's frank i have no idea i will
have a little something spritzer i
assume i'll have whatever you're having
so do you know the region mr nilo well
if it's in the amazon river i know it
and lady i could tell you of all the
places in the world you can go the last
place you want to go is la grimas di
crestal no but i do
and i will oh but you won't
pants you can't get there nobody can get
there and if they could they wouldn't
it's not a fun vacation well i'm not
here for a vacation
where'd you get the map isn't it
extraordinary
the detail and the care he took it was
drawn by aguirre's cartographer and it
belonged to my father who used to tell
me all about the tears of the moon when
i was a little girl
[Laughter]
that's why you want to go your daddy's
bedtime stories look can you get us
there or not this has just been a
colossal waste of my time i could get
you there but you have to consider the
dengue fever anaconda plus look lady
that's the home of the actual puka
matuna
they're the ones that like to eat you
and wear your eyes for beats look lady i
gotta be honest with you let's do
something that's safe so me you and your
pants we can go for a ride around town
that'd be fun i'll show you some
waterfalls you look like you like
waterfalls and also show you the herd of
pygmy elephants we just found let's go
see some elephants
i lost my key for that thing did you
i did
well that's never gonna do it you're
gonna hurt yourself those are very sharp
mr nelo i've spent my childhood playtime
with the toddler pickpockets of delhi so
there we go allow me to manage my own
safety if that's all right now shall we
negotiate a price or shall i just cast
about for another skipper
two beers two steaks me paloma pour for
more who's paying for all this oh mr
neelo insisted it was his treats that's
right
i consider 5000 real more than adequate
10 000 i take you there myself i am my
best captain oh you're my smartest fine
ten thousand ten thousand to bring you
there alive if i have to bring you back
dead it's fifteen thousand why should i
pay more dead dead i'd have to carry you
that's a lot harder lady
twenty dead or alive okay but i get paid
in full when we turn back before la
grima sticker style why ever would we be
turning back well you're gonna beg me to
turn back
first sign of the rapids well i look
forward to disappointing you
lily look what i found at the hotel bar
ah mr nilo
he drives a hard bargain but he met his
match with me negotiated him down to 50
000.
who's your friend
not mr nilo not mr melo no
so i suppose that would make you enjoy
your mia frank as in frank owes me money
frank
of course it's all making perfect sense
i suppose it's only a scam if you fall
for it
well thank you mr frank i hope we never
meet again mr nilo hello
did you just whistle at me twelve
thousand hey excuse me ten thousand
aren't you missing an engine cinderine
he could not get you as far as the
outhouse in fact his porter kind of
looks like an altar you're never gonna
find a faster boat in the harbor than
laquila plus
she has the finest bath in all brazil
why should i trust you
i'm the only one that could get you
there
[Music]
careful they could smell fear i am not
afraid might be me
warm
liquid fear
oh
a little bit more fear just came up
uh
[Music]
foreign
he did it
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you rank wolf
jungle navigation best rates in town
completely jackpot free
thank you
you are a lot of things that i don't
really care for
but you are
capable so
twelve thousand fifteen thousand twelve
thousand fifteen
12. half now half upon return alive
and if we have a deal i'll meet you at
the docks with our luggage you have a
deal good luckily we'll be ready first
thing in the morning oh no frank owes me
money we're going to depart in 10
minutes now it gets dark in two hours
does it
we should probably leave in ten minutes
not now
i said not now
you did good proxima you're a good girl
you were a little late and you bit me
way too hard
you did good
[Music]
jungle doesn't care how pretty your
dresses are you're never gonna get all
your luggage on my boat not mine
mine and i assure you every one of these
items is entirely necessary for my
survival
well with all this extra added weight
we'd be lucky to even get out of the
harbor so no dinner without dinner
jacket is hardly well
dinner is it
now
be a good chap
what are you gonna do with those birds
we're gonna stuff them and send them to
paris no you're not
how much
do you think you're doing
see what happens next order the entire
movie
disney's jungle cruise now available
[Music]
you